[Música]
vamos a hablar de economía con Juan
Pablo lucumí Juan Pablo Buen día para
usted Buenos días Ángela y comenzamos
por nuestro continente en América Latina
estuvo la reunión de los presidentes de
Brasil y de Argentina a que acuerdos
llegaron Ángela Pues fue una reunión
larga a la que llegaron a la conclusión
que deben reunirse mucho más para
encontrar puntos en común de lo que sí
dieron un mensaje claro después de su
encuentro fue sobre su deseo de
encontrar un mecanismo que les permita
evitar el uso del dólar estadounidense
entre los acuerdos comerciales
bilaterales según el Ministerio de
Hacienda de Brasil el plan propuesto
tendría una línea de crédito para
financiar a las empresas brasileñas que
exportan Argentina con la intención de
evitar el uso del dólar y teniendo en
cuenta que Brasil es el mayor socio
comercial de Argentina este plan se
gesta mientras la economía de Argentina
atraviesa uno de sus momentos más
frágiles con una corrida del peso en los
mercados financieros que causó una
fuerte devaluación de la moneda local
una fuga de Divisas periodos de sequía
que ha las exportaciones una inflación
también que llega a principios de año
superó el 100% y que no ha cedido la
respuesta del gobierno de izquierdista
de Fernández Es que la derecha tiene la
culpa de la crisis del dólar en su país
pero escuchemos las declaraciones de los
mandatarios desde Brasilia de verdad
celebro y valoro
como como país y como gobierno
han tomado la decisión de ayudar tomar a
una crisis
brasileros sigan exportando para que las
continuas
y nos habían pedido que hagamos algunos
deberes
para ayudar haciendo una discusión para
ayudarla a Argentina
a los empresarios brasileños
el presidente de Brasil hablaba de China
y precisamente China tiene un papel
importante en todo este escenario pues
recientemente Argentina llegó a un
acuerdo con Beijing que permite a sus
empresas pagar las importaciones chinas
con yuanes y cuando Lula estuvo en
Shanghai aplaudió el desarrollo de un
acuerdo entre Brasil y China para usar
el yuan en su comercio bilateral y
además criticó el uso del dólar
estadounidense en el comercio
internacional y en los programas del
fondo monetario internacional en este
momento todos rechazando el dólar pues
se llama mucho la atención esta
iniciativa de Lola da Silva que sabemos
intenta a toda costa alejarse del dólar
que ha dicho públicamente no entiendo
porque dependemos del dólar y pues que
hizo esta propuesta de la moneda única
que revitalizó hace algunos meses que
finalmente no quedó en nada no no quedó
nada pero ya están haciendo algunas
acciones argentinas está pues ligado ahí
veremos que suceda también vamos ahora a
Europa hay datos de desempleo en Italia
en marzo hubo un buen panorama para la
tercera economía de la zona Euro la tasa
de desempleo en Italia bajo a 7,8% en
marzo desde el 7,9% de febrero luego de
que se crearan unos 22.000 puestos de
trabajo en el tercer mes de este año con
esto la tasa de empleo de marzo estuvo
por debajo del pronóstico de 8,0 por
ciento que habían previsto 11 analistas
encuestados por la agencia de noticias
routers y se consagra como la lectura
más baja desde abril de 2020 cuando los
italianos dejaron de buscar trabajo
durante el confinamiento de Kobe 19 en
otras lecturas de datos la economía
italiana creció un 0,5% más de lo
esperado en el primer trimestre lo que
supuso una recuperación tras una caída
del 0,1% del producto interno bruto a
finales del año pasado
Juan Pablo además tenemos el escenario
inflacionario que ya empieza a verse
reflejado especialmente en medio oriente
y esto lo dice el fmi y llegaba un poco
tarde pero el informe pues llega
contundente porque la inflación le hemos
reportado aquí pues ha estado en
diferentes partes del mundo ahora
especialmente afectando a ese sector
Asia central medio oriente según el
fondo monetario internacional las
economías de medio oriente hacia central
probablemente perderán su ritmo de
crecimiento por la elevada inflación y
los constantes incrementos de las tasas
de interés que usan sus bancos centrales
para tratar de contener el aumento de
precios el informe dice que mientras que
las economías dependientes del petróleo
de los estados árabes del Golfo y otros
en la región han cosechado los
beneficios de los elevados precios del
crudo otros países como Pakistán han
visto colapsar el crecimiento después de
una inundación sin precedentes el verano
pasado escuchemos la perspectiva del FM
after years and 2022 Bueno después de un
año de buen crecimiento en 2022
este año veremos una desaceleración
crezca a una velocidad casi similar el
próximo año este año estamos viendo que
la inflación nuevamente es el problema
desafiante para la mayoría de los países
y para aquellos que tienen un alto nivel
de deuda el desafío del aumento de la
tasa de interés a nivel mundial así como
también el endurecimiento de la política
monetaria los está afectando
vamos con Los indicadores y vamos a
revisar primero América Latina con un
dato que de pronto le interesa a usted
que tiene un automóvil en nuestra región
la mayoría de bolsas cerraron en terreno
negativo y solo la bolsa de México
presentó una leve ganancia del
0,11%, que más perdió fue el principal
indicador de Colombia cuando cerró con
un 3,40% en números rojos entre otras
cosas luego de conocerse que el precio
de la gasolina subió 600 pesos
colombianos desde la medianoche de este
miércoles de este martes por decisión
del gobierno nacional al cierre de Asia
también fue en su mayoría negativo Hong
Kong perdió un 1,18 por ciento Sydney un
0,96% mientras Tokio cerró con una leve
alza del 0,2% no Claro que me interesa Y
claro que no nos beneficia Para nada la
subida del precio de la gasolina pero
pues hay que también hacer la claridad
no esto venía siendo anunciado por el
gobierno que iba a pasar y que va a
seguir pasando así es ya ya estaba el
anuncio Pues por fin llegó este aumento
vamos a ver cómo reaccionan los gremios
bueno Juan Pablo finalmente de la cifra
para cerrar este segmento Ángela son los
7.800 empleos que serán reemplazados por
la Inteligencia artificial en
International business machines en los
próximos cinco años la empresa dijo que
pausará la contratación y que por lo
menos el 30% de los roles no orientados
a los clientes son los que serían
reemplazados por la Inteligencia
artificial en los próximos años
afirmaciones que hizo el propio director
ejecutivo de la compañía esta semana y
la Inteligencia artificial sigue siendo
noticia y sigue siendo preocupante Juan
Pablo ahí ve a los libretistas de
Hollywood protestando por ese mismo tema
así es muchas gracias a ustedes ya nos
vemos más adelante ahora con mucho más